Will some ancient messages just never be read.
No matter how hard we try.
[inaudible]
history's got something to hide from you.
That's okay because the last time we armed you with a new skill decipherment
you're ready to go. Just point you in a direction. But what to deciphered?
Oh, I really wish I could remember the book,
but in a librarian Ithica there is or there was some book with a neat graph that
breaks down the problem for us. Bloop down a chart with two axes. Yep.
A chart.
We're getting into this now look at a script and ask yourself two simple
questions. Can I read the graphemes and do I know the language?
If you know how to read the writing system but not the language,
you can learn the language.
If you have enough samples and some way of reading into those samples.
A little translation here,
familiar name there just to crack open the doorway for you.
A good example is north Piscean.
These ancient northern Italians carved their language into the Novi Laura Stele
and we can read it. Sort of what I mean is we can sound out the graphemes,
but practically,
since there aren't many north pricing texts lying around for us to learn from,
we don't know what the says. Don't cry.
Think about known languages with known writing systems. They're easy.
If you can already read the graphemes and the language. It's simple.
Recognition task. Oh, that's Swahili.
Written in the Latin alphabet and there Swahili written in the Arabic object.
Wow. We really need to cover these writing terms. What about languages?
We don't know. Written in writing systems,
we can't read who possibly impossible with enough of the right kinds of
examples.
We can figure out a language from a script or a script from a language,
but if we're missing both this square bricks, last times model of decipherment,
we're left with one lone box, known language,
unknown writing system. This is our box in this box.
We find all of the decipherment of the past and those taunting mysteries still
waiting to be cracked.
This is the realm of brilliant hunches that made history and crank theories that
went nowhere. Stay tuned and subscribe for tales of decipherment.
[inaudible].